okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about predicate logic and
the idea well let's take a look at
example 1 find predicate model logic
okay find predicate proof okay so we
have essentially a mortal queue
no we're asserting Socrates is mortal no
it's it's a mortal q we're asking asking
toluca okay so it's an interesting
question how we would best represent
something like Socrates is mortal I mean
how would we naturally represent that I
mean this is sort of a symbolic
discourse language type thinkers we
haven't had to do things like you know
the predicates we've had well anyway
okay all right but any case so but where
are these definitions I mean you're not
oh I see that this is can be arbitrary
these are arbitrary definitions right
there defined by the axioms in effect
okay so for all X all men are mortal
Socrates a man
why is that women that's an assertion
right so this is a different kind of
thing so I see so the eye I see I I get
it I'm slowly slowly understanding so
there's an the axioms consist of a list
of things that are true mm-hmm well it
could be a for all and there implies or
it could merely be Socrates is a man
okay right they're both valid
first-order logic statements
okay so how would I just do the
computation in our system of what's true
I mean in other words how would I just
get the answer to Socrates is mortal
here
I mean that work that's a
I guess the general version of that
question is given an axiom system how do
you enumerate truth theorems
right well no it's given an axiom system
I mean how would I resolve okay in our
system right now how would I resolve
what is the function that would tell me
given this okay
I guess you are thinking of full
simplify or refine I would think so but
is that gonna work with predicates like
this they can sorry I'm I'm not sure
they can handle general first-order
logic this won't work in full simplify
I'm almost certain right but so so that
should be possible to make that work yes
yes absolutely okay so this is merely
the proof version of that right would
what's the thing that just tries to
resolve that refine is that not correct
yes okay but I guess finally is one of
the many things that full simplify tries
well I understand that but if all I
wanted to do was not simplify but just
resolve that that true or false how
would I do that
I think it's refined yes perhaps reduce
I think refine the fact that we're all
confused about this isn't well I don't
know that that should be determined um
Adam would presumably know that but I
think it's really important that we have
a way to do that so I mean in effect
we'll simplify is already calling into
the back end a fine equational proof
when it does the equations so it
wouldn't be that hard to modify it to do
what first-order statements fair enough
fair enough fair enough so that's a
reasonable thing to do but now my
comment here boy I mean okay I'm gonna
make a matter comment which is you know
what predicate logic really is it's so
nice when they're explicit examples with
just anyway never mind I like this okay
so
okay so whatever this is I have no idea
that's a subject that's a critical my
god why that critical pears all over the
place here well but that's that's one of
the main things we want to discuss today
the fact that even though this says find
predicate proof it is still mostly
equational in behavior and there proof
is still equation so one of the thing
and and I will defend it is that this
should be still find equation of proof
generalized to support first of all a
logic right this is a weird situation
where it's like the theorem and the
axioms are first-order but the proof
apart from some initial steps is
essentially equational and the initial
steps of these colonization things or
something yeah right so this is
essentially doing a simplification that
there is a there's a very common theorem
prover called e which seems to perform
reasonably well in these kind of theorem
proving competitions which operates on
basically the same principle where you
take the first order statement you do
skolemization you set it equal to a
tautology in boolean algebra and then
you do a query gional simplification on
that and obviously the equation will
evaluate to be true if and only if the
original statement was correct and so
you're just using the fast you know
superposition calculus that we have
equation or logic to do first-order
logic okay
those pink steps are where we've either
scholar you know it could sort of
equation wise the first-order logic
statements can you see that is that this
what yes right so what does that mean
what is it okay okay so a quick equation
like vaccine for axioms four and five
are the equation alized forms of the two
axioms you put in so so there that
that's just a slightly modified version
of the statement you put in and we've
set it equal to this tautology which is
a or not a in both cases so
okay so one of the things you're
revealing here is that this is an
equation alized path through doing this
proof right and you're saying there
could be another path through doing this
proof that may not be you know may not
involve equation realization sure yeah I
mean there are there are many ways of
doing first-order logic
theorem proving this just happens to be
a particularly fast method although it
could end up being a method option for
okay so I'm kind of agreeing with Jose
here that this is if this is because
once you have a proof okay
let's sort of loop this back a bit okay
we don't have stylistic options for
integrate for instance we could have a
stylistic option but let me give you an
example I don't even know how you get
the trigonometric solution to the cubic
out of our system is there a way to do
that
so in other words that's a case where we
could have a stylistic option gosh if we
don't have that that should be in the
function repository they I mean the fact
that we gone 30 years and nobody's asked
for a trigonometric solution to the
cubic is an interesting sign um
but anyway I mean it's in a sense it's a
stylistic option for what comes out in
the world of proofs the proof is not
merely you know
a means to an end it is an end in itself
so to speak and therefore it matters
what comes out and so there could be
stylistic options about the proof that
matter so therefore there's the equation
alized style and there's I mean even a
method option you know we don't really
think in most cases a method option
shouldn't really affect what comes out
it might affect you know I don't know
whether the thing has this kind of
cropping or that kind of cropping but
it's it's only a small effect whereas in
this case of these proofs potentially
the method is everything because it's
the difference between you're gonna get
a trigonometric solution out and you're
gonna get some algebraic solution out
and so on or am i confused know that
that's that sounds completely correct no
the rights I mean in a sense by saying
find equation or proof we are pre
setting certain expectations about the
type of proof that's gonna come out I
mean you know there's also yeah okay all
right well let's look at some other
examples here there is another argument
which is that some users have complained
that they couldn't solve find sorry
first-order logic problems we'd find the
question of proof fine so then when the
argument is is finished because we
should just do it that way then I mean
they expect it we can make an argument
for it we should just do it okay so what
is this
there exists so this is a more complex
lightly more complicated example of the
same thing so it before we just had
Universal quantifiers this is to show
that we can also eliminate existential
quantifiers through scholarization which
is a slightly more complicated procedure
because you have to introduce these
so-called skolem variables to get rid of
the exists so you showing me what the
puts inside the proof object oh is that
oh that is hidden for I sorry I should
have I should have thought is it really
grotesque or not no no I mean it'll look
the same
okay truth is most of these proofs are
pretty useless to humans I mean even the
very fact that you're seeing a or not a
as the version of true it's just pretty
human you know
pretty human hostile I think something
like this is good to understand the
method being used in simple examples
like this but yeah for complicated cases
you know for complicated cases we have
no idea how is anybody's gonna use this
stuff I mean other than I'm writing a
paper I want to put you know I need to
show that there's a proof print the
proof in the paper I don't know what
people are gonna do with this I mean
it's it's it's really an interesting I
mean it you know it's very interesting
to be able to say here is a proof and to
be able to discuss some statistics or
prove some things but when it comes to
detailed reading I mean I guess one
question is when you know if we put
these into Wolfram Alpha are people
going to find them useful how long have
we done any of that have we put any
proofs into Wolfram Alpha anybody know
one of the summer school projects from
this year will be an instance of the
plan is to have that implemented of the
reading minimization one
right but which was she using the the
theorem prover or did she was she using
rules no she was easy she had her own
rule ontology okay yeah that will be a
nice thing to have but that's a I mean
but that's a show steps that's
essentially a show steps play as opposed
to a mainstream equational proof type
play which we could also have right I
mean although it's for a you know a
different set of people but it's still
yeah okay well fair enough let's keep
going here
what if tptp thousands of problems for
theorem provers there's a big collection
of these things of equation of equation
allure predicate or what
everything equation of predicate
higher-order it's it's sort of the
standard against which they're improvers
are compared we know when people do
these annual competitions and things
they use problems from the tptp
so I use this in particular because I
wants to compare the performance against
vampire to see how it did ours is I mean
it's same order of magnitude I mean
vampires a bit faster but it's not bad
fair enough
so so if you look at that database and
you look at the sort of pie chart of
what's there maybe maybe I can even just
do it
I'm right what um what kinds of things
are there I mean in other words there's
there's equational stuff there's
first-order stuff
yep there's higher-order stuff and then
the I mean there's accommodate there's
there are these relatively simple ones
which tend to be kind of logic puzzle II
type things and then n anything that
sort of non-trivial technical math
involves quite a lot of error what are
these actual systems
it's cool
this seems highly relevant to us
we should have an import mechanism that
can read x-files yep absolutely
but this also seems relevant I mean I
don't know what
these are in terms of what order logic
they are on things right but we but this
is potentially something we could get
into axiomatic theory or have axiomatic
theory call into or something that's
what I would think I'd never run across
this okay all right I think I think I
mentioned it when we had an axiomatic
theory meeting a while ago I think I
mentioned this but we kind of decided
that because we only supported equation
of logic it wasn't worth doing but I
think as soon as we have first order
it's definitely something we should look
into okay well how what other things
um
okay
um
you
um
you
let's see ah he didn't spellcheck oh
well um but what other things are in
here do we know so what does this mean
what is LCL mean problem domains this
will be some branch of math I know I
don't know I've taught offhand what LCL
is let's take a look
basic information
you
you
or whether they have the information on
what the quick guide ok basic test
problems logic calculator looks like
where I found a there's a technical
report which has all of the explanations
of all the acronyms or what are they I
mean each one is it is a domain of math
yeah LCL is logic calculate their Henkin
models set theory graph theory algebra
this is really cool I agree
Sonia examples three four and five all
ones that I took from tptp
Oh domain structure okay
as really cool so pH I claims to be
philosophy
so that would be the ones like the
Socrates once and things right well we
should still be able to run Rafi
you
you
you
my gosh this is rather grotesque he's an
ontological argument cytosine
from Anselm type things yeah okay so
can prove the existence or inexistence
of God
my gosh oh we could add our our solution
to all right I mean this seems like a
really good place to UM so for example
here on earth would be in biology
is that the proof of can the snail walk
up the whatever based on its
not so many happen cell has a pot unlike
you could point plasmodial slime mold no
plasmodial slime mold is living entity
great
let's look at like topology that seems
interesting
you
you
wow this is pretty elaborate okay so
this is more so what do we think what is
this is this something we're gonna be
able to deal with or is this some kind
of higher order
well the topology stuff will be higher
order in general but I mean certainly
all the first-order stuff we could in
principle write a parser that just
converts everything into our
representation okay so if we were going
to go through and make other theorem
provers um the UM what um you know
what's the next step beyond predicate
okay by the way see 252 from our live
stream is asking do we have materials
that could recommend for implementing a
predicate logic theorem prover well this
is a predicate logic theorem prover but
I don't know how I don't know whether
people have implemented ones directly
didn't didn't y'all summer school
implement one directly in wolf language
yes yeah though the resolution one right
so I think that some and presumably he
has his project on the online um I can
post it on the light stream chatot or in
second action yeah um
I even just each other pull it up just
for fun okay
as the owners are going to get back to
doing that temporal logic do we put them
off horribly by the fact that temporal
logic review didn't go so well um anyway
okay
but but so if we were going to go on
past um
the
[Music]
um
um sorry if we if we're going to go on
past you know past predicate logic
well by the way I mean as far as I can
see this looks just fine what you've
done here I mean I don't have any
objection okay
I mean these literals yeah I mean I
think it's fine I mean these are
variables for all P there's a quantified
three variables here I mean literals of
some kind
kind of fun that it's possible to do
this Wow
I mean how can you conclude anything
from this though other than what's truth
I mean in other words what's the next
thing you would like to know I mean
other than the fact that this is a
beautiful wall chart what's the next
thing ok so there's there's two levels
of hierarchy one is um the UM
um what am I saying
one is um kind of what's true and sort
of the the final thing is I'll show me
the whole proof okay but the question is
what is there an intermediate stage do
we know any intermediate stage that's
useful I mean there's like popular
llamas but who cares those are also very
machine-generated disgorgement so to
speak
early the next important thing is
finding content examples okay you mean
if it isn't true find the
counter-examples exactly in fact one
could say we know that these examples
are true but we might be starting with
things and we don't know whether they
are true or not and for I guess just
yeah the system will just stay there
trying to prove it so we need the
opposite right so right I agree found
find counter examples would be a great
function to have I think you talked
about that a bit Jonathan right I have a
person type of that but we never got a
design meeting set up why isn't it
basically just the same as this find
counter examples just like find
instances yeah so it is quite different
because you know this is a purely
syntactical thing whereas you know to
find a counter example you have to
construct a model it's you know find
equational proof is on find predicate
proof is is proof there etic and a find
counter example function is model
theoretic and so it's actually I was
gonna say that the the positive case of
what Jose was saying is I guess one
intermediate thing you might want to say
is for a theorem that's actually true
can you find a sort of minimal model
that demonstrates that it's true so in
this case the model in which it's true
because there might be a model in which
I mean if Ihram is not globally true
there might be a model for which it is
true right right so you can find you can
find models even you know even in cases
where the statement is independent of
the axioms because there are some and
which is true so much it's false yeah
exactly but but - so that is the analog
of find counter example is find a model
for which the thing is true
which might not tell you very much but
it at least tells you something okay bit
but why is the counter-examples case um
explain to me what is specifically
problematic about having to construct
the model so in the case of equational
logic i see the model would be
essentially a multiplication table for
the operators yes exactly exactly so so
in the find counter example function
that I made this was a probably a very
far from optimal way of doing it but
essentially I just enumerated
multiplication tables in which every
quantified variable was assigned a
number and then every sort of every
function was converted into a function
of arithmetic and then I just enumerated
such multiplication tables until
eventually we found one which the
statement was falsified
okay well it's not necessarily the case
that the operators can be in terms of
arithmetic right mean they just ISM no
women the operators are just a
multiplication table and what you're
saying is what we're saying there is
imagine in the model that the model is
simply industry indexed by integers
right exactly
okay because the rhythm arithmetic is
universal so we know that eventually it
will have to if there is a counter
example it will find it but it may be
what does it have to do with arithmetic
I mean it doesn't why are we talking
about arithmetic I mean it's just the
multiplication table for the for the
operator F is an arbitrary thing
involving those indices right
it just says index 7 combined with index
2 gives index 3 or something mm-hmm so
essentially it's it's some it is
precisely I mean in you know like in the
MKS book we have from the you know we
have examples of this there right so
like like the the the the classic page
so to speak
pull it up
you
you know I know that's a good sign our
bats
times per day I actually use this thing
um
you
this picture here right this is showing
models of certain axiom systems right
so that's another function that we need
right is the is the just generate models
and then
you're saying once a one function is
generate models so so what we could say
you know we could imagine a thing that
is called find equational models
I've essentially axioms
and then we might have some details
about the size and things like this
right
you know min sighs max sighs well max
sighs and then we might have
yeah min max go go ahead isn't the
interesting case where you give not just
axioms but also a hypothesis because I
mean enumerated models for axioms it's
just kind of trivial what you care about
in most cases models of axioms where a
particular statement is true don't you
know because you could always just add
the statement to the accident if that's
what you care about okay
okay so this would be either sand
interesting function so I mean this is
basically doing this right I mean I had
very efficient code for getting these by
the way and um
sometimes yeah you see it's look at
these numbers one six seven seven seven
two one six oh that's a big number and I
think I may have had yeah I mean I have
have had good code for doing that which
we could still use it's low level code
but I don't see why we shouldn't use it
it's probably disembody it's probably a
library linkable code I bet it was a you
know a double STP program back back then
okay so then um so we could have fined
equational models we have fined
counter-examples
okay so find instance right now we have
find instance
which finds an instance of
young principal find instances doing
your find a model that fits it so nodes
find instance of F of a B equals F of B
a
doesn't find instance have the same idea
of
but but find instance doesn't allow you
to define assumptions or axioms that's
the central difference but it should
that third argument which is right now
our domain should allow that right so
that this would be fine instance of f
well here what we really want is we
quantify over these four all a B this
thing here find this such that axioms
that will be the form right that would I
find an instance that would find an
instance of F or multiple instances of F
fat so the representation of F here is
as a pure function presumably
I turn principle we could solve this to
get F being NAND or some such other
thing but otherwise what F is going to
be is something that says you know 3 2 1
5 1 1 or something I think it has to be
um yeah I think it's this right I'm not
mistaken enough there's a better way to
do it but it's something like that sorry
I'm not sure the structure of the
arguments is correct because the current
defined instance takes a domain in the
third argument so this Amane might be
the specification of which models we are
interested in I see as opposed to the
axioms right so perhaps we need your
previous idea of having the axioms
together with there yeah ok fair enough
fair enough fair enough so model type
basically is what you're saying here so
this then says axioms yeah it doesn't
really matter what's an axiom or what's
a hypothesis just you're trying to find
things for which all those things are
true right and this follows what
synthetic geometry is doing in find
instance ah
right where it says I see where it just
has a bucket of of statements and it
then says what's true the mathematical
musings on our live stream has a very
amusing example of find an instance of
an animal such that but now I think we
actually have that because we can
actually do that using um entity using
the entity system right I mean we can do
that right now we just say entity of
poets don't that we yet can do the
animal sub case but we do species let's
do Mountain such
that our elevation what is it what is
that what is the thing for a mountain um
I have to go fairly soon
um well certainly some things like this
but but greater than height of Mount
Fuji
back there we go alright there may be a
lot of them and that cool that just
worked so it's interesting that that is
a so that's a thing well our model is
actually something in the real world
right
which is very weird I mean that's a
domain that is a real world domain so
what I'm saying whereas normally we are
just taking idealized by the way um
pointing out here that um why aren't
those green dots brothers spaced out why
don't why do they why are they so
clustered up I'm not sure I can look
into the waiting of the proof graph I
was still I was tweaking that the other
day fair enough oh but by the way I just
sent you a emailed you a screenshot of
fine country a fine equation or counter
example just to show you how it
currently works
you
you
you
my god so the operator is just as a pure
as I say a pure function based on
arithmetic operators and then you assign
numbers to each of the I think variables
crazy I don't think you should or if you
guys just do a multiplication table I
think it's much more stable than
arithmetic I mean yes obviously you can
represent anything I mean you can you
can do you know you didn't girdle number
it if you want to I mean the poster it's
just a I don't know a multiplication
table seemed kind of unnecessarily for
both at least in the cases I was trying
but sure I'll have it be a sparse array
if you don't like if the multiplication
table is verbose to make a bit sparse
array I'm sure you can do that okay
weathers I don't care thing although
there may not be a don't care I mean
there may be there may be a thing where
the multiplication table is not fully
determined which will be interesting to
know right um
okay but I was just asking so I really
like these ideas of trying to do this
okay and I this one we can probably make
it quite efficient for the equational
case right um I mean maybe that already
exists from some of the tools that we
have or maybe we can use the old code
that I wrote 20 years ago or something
you know that I used for the boolean
algebra search um the and the fact that
those numbers are so huge in the nks
book does suggest that the thing was
quite efficient um the okay um um I'm
gonna have to run in a moment here so I
I this looks great
I I'm you know I don't see problems with
it
I just wanted to ask you know sort of
the the hierarchy above the find you
know equational logic predicate
predicate logic proof what's the next
stage in the sort of world of fancy
theorem proving
so systems like isn't bail as far as I
can tell if things based on hull seem to
have a general approach for doing you
know all of higher order logic
essentially there's a there's something
called the LCF approach which i don't
completely understand I read about it a
while ago but essentially you can it
allows for some dramatic reduction of
all higher order logic sin to some
simplified system and so I'm not I'm not
sure if we could make that work with the
proof object art school women hold yeah
I know that about that stuff that I mean
the collaboration that Michaels been
working on with the lien people how is
this relevant to this do we know it's
still moving forward and eventually I
think we could have another proved
generator based on type theory yes I see
and so that would be a proof generator
that would have the same syntax as leads
but or not yes same same thing same
syntax using also the same proof object
but the internals will be slightly
different different properties perhaps
because they are that we are interested
in different representations right okay
I unfortunately need to run but this was
this is really good I mean I I think we
should just go ahead and you know do the
integration okay okay excellent all
right thanks the old soon okay thanks to
the folks on the live stream